hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play mad father oK
you've been itching for another RPG
horror game and this one was pretty
highly recommended I'll admit the
paranoiac wasn't all that scary but some
people have been saying that this is one
of the best right up there with witch's
house so I'm gonna go with this one next
so let's get into it
the music was lovely by the way I love a
game with great music in the beginning
hello
scenario illustration by sin you know
supposedly a lot of these horror games
were made a long time ago like back in
the 90s and they're only coming around
now but some of these games are made
more recently I don't know how easy
and/or difficult it is to make one of
these games I assume they're with any
other type of game development is
equally challenging to create all the
art and programming but the RPG editor
is there for convenience of other people
and as you can see from this graphics
can come from pre-made sources
royalty-free stuff and all that so if
you want to get creative with something
why not start with an RPG not a bad
Avenue some of the best game makers
probably start with RPGs themselves and
some of the best games in the world or
RPGs okay anyway let's see what we've
got going on here
oh whoops oh oh no like oh whoops I
thought I had to press something and I
gotta skip through the beginning there I
hope there wasn't anything important
father hello oh I'm a beautiful little
girl again instead of bloody father are
you in there
father uh uh how many times have I told
you not to come down here sorry father
but um I'm too scared to sleep on my own
ah ah don't worry you're never alone
that's not very reassuring your late
mother is always there at your side you
mean like a ghost she's always looking
after you aiya you mean like a ghost
okay now please get to bed
yes Father I've got some diabolical work
to do oh sorry father
tomorrow's yes the anniversary of her
death
yeah we'll visit her grave together okay
father
now back to bed please I'll be resting
to shortly okay
I'll be resting to shortly okay I'm
guessing I'll start to places soon so
stop who who said that No
wha what help me is that coming from the
room help oh okay I know fathers secret
my father is a scientist he loves
research and is always locked up in the
lab in the basement and have always
heard things from that lab animal and
human screams even at a young age I knew
what my father doing so I pretended I
wasn't looking that I didn't know or
hear anything I feigned ignorance the
whole time because I loved father yeah
about that that's not the only secret I
know when mom and I weren't around he
and his helper a whole
okay fine sample I shall dispose if the
remaining materials are myself she looks
kind of creepy doll like that can wait
come Maria doctor - shut up nurse mmm
what doctor mmm she's aware of our
relationship mmm what does it matter I
don't believe she's fond of me that is
the problem the girl will be 11 soon
it's a troublesome age to be sure he
kind her please make sure she is never
harmed she is my most precious
okie-dokie all right then shut up Darce
shut up and make out with me okey-dokey
some flattened by there what is that
hello somebody
Oh I'm asleep in my bed with my creepy
dolls in the room wakey-wakey time for
it's midnight
today's a day mom went to heaven mom
okay
alright I can never sleep when I think
about mom all right I'm starting to play
now portrait of mom cool mom hello so
shiny you're dead way to be you look
like you're in the same dresses ah the
other lady from witch's house what
should I do mom I do love father but she
scares me
yeah no joke she always looking at me
with those eyes I hate her but I know
father likes her the father and her got
married I guess she would be my new mom
I don't want it to be my new mom I don't
need a new mom there's only one mom in
the world for me mom why did you have to
go that's what we're gonna find out I
bet sir I bet it's something diabolical
a dress her full of clothes dress her
full of clothes teddy bear am I gonna
cut off its limbs a beloved doll the
doll I got from father it's so old and
warm
I bet the first fanart that's gonna be
created as me as the father saying shut
up nurse and make out with me to the to
the lady over there that's what it's
gonna be
hello father I bought you a present daya
yay it's dull yes good job kid
thank you Father what a pretty doll it's
almost like it's real I don't trust
anything it's game I've learned from
other games that I play before that I
need not trust anything holla
okay back to playing can I look at that
wait what was that
it's so dark out mmm plain a little more
lady red egg what something fell out
what did what's this got gem okay
gems are hidden in various places some
require doing special events to get you
can see your gem count on the menu find
them all and dot dot dot you get a
special ending I get Horus the traitor
snowball the pet rabbit poor snowball
snowball sprite not to live through this
story just saying what would you see Lou
the room feels cold all of a sudden I'm
kind of scared I should get back to bed
not yet little girl a box full of
memories what's outside I should go to
bed a fine oh you could do big leg good
night who are you saying good night to
me good eye good night okay
those are you know what creepy little
girls start singing you sing so well I
oh it's me I'm singing oh I stopped
thinking right then father would you
look this way
give me a moment just put this here what
are you doing there father
yes it's finished oh look I guess a
flower crown it's adorable does it look
good on me yes I think it suits you well
thanks father even though you're psycho
crazy thank you Father
I'm sorry I can't always play with you
father it's all right I'm glad I could
play with you today father boy this
little girl sure has a deep voice energy
oh my you two were playing hmm mom I'm
screwing up all the voices now look
father maybe a flower crown that's
wonderful darling
it looks great on you aiya so you played
with him all day maybe this is why you
didn't like the mom yeah we should do
this again father yes we should next
time your mother should join in well I
look forward to it cough oh she's sick
that's how she died I'm sorry it's just
another fit hack wheeze don't push
yourself if you're not feeling well
come get some medicine from Marya it
should help you get better no I can get
that myself mom are you hurt you're okay
right sorry to worry you I'm perfectly
fine don't look so anxious please oh
yeah your smile keeps me going if I
can't see you smiling it only makes me
worry mom
okay now let's get back for dinner I
made hamburger steak tonight your
favorite aya ray I love mom's hamburgers
right father
ha ha of course oh sorry ah ha ha her
hamburgers are the best in the world is
that just trying to insert Americanized
food into their just jam it right in
there
not like pot roast me low roast quail we
were so happy then there was Mario but
even so the three of us were happy
finally so I can sorta I can sort of
guess what happened to this lovely
little family starting to guess
Mario's problem here Marya is the sexy
nurse who is a big problem to everybody
in this place correct okay huh
that scream father something must have
happened I'll go check on father okay I
have a bad feeling me too
alright the music's good what's this
sound is that a voice okay eek yeah my
feeling go Appa where you come from
ah what the hell
zom zoms here no don't this way
who's that come this way I'm a-coming
I'm not gonna do zom zoms disappear out
of nowhere and i'm going to go back see
like i don't want to go back we'll sock
it up little girl alright fine we won't
go back then who the hell are you who
the hell has the audacity this way you
got blood on your shirt I don't trust
you no III won't wha some little wrong
you got some on your face
spill some spaghetti or some day yeah
yeah I'd run too ah run the other way
now back in the room what who the hell
are you many interesting books in this
room here do you like books my damn wall
you don't be so crass with formulas
salesman salesman bow
call me oka I hope to get you know you
young lady but it's quite troublesome to
think the court should Lloyd around the
house
corpses those marshals back there they
like masters from a story
why would monsters like that well it's a
curse what you saw with the corpses of
your father's test subjects or overcome
with anger those deceased have been
brought back by the power of the curse
to take revenge on your father of course
what so father is in danger I have to
save him why is that to achieve his
desires he has killed so many people as
part of his experiments this is his
retribution you must have realized by
now your father's true nature and yet
you wish to save him maybe not
you
okay I my perhaps she cannot yet
understand their sorrow okay still got a
phase say Bobby he's the only family I
have left
father was always kind to me he's the
only father I have and I promised mom to
okay
the red eyed stranger gave Jack the
power to curse others and Jack said
thank you red eyed stranger now I can
have my revenge hey mom
yes aiyah what's father always up to
down below ah
after down okay it's very difficult job
you'll understand when you're older
aiyah I want to be older soon then aiyah
whatever happens you shouldn't hate your
father mom what's the matter
of course I wouldn't hate father I see
mom do you not like father no nothing
like that
I'm just like you ayah I love your
father just as much woo he can be a bit
unpredictable so let's support each
other no matter what promise yeah now
back to the story the red eyes stranger
who was the red eyed stranger in my room
is part of that book it's all part of
the book it's all on this little girl's
mind she's psycho bonkers crazy mom
whatever happens I love father so don't
worry okay I got it
whoa whoa whoa I just skipped on
something a crow ah a saving crow I was
just wondering about that I was just
about to say nothing about to saving
this so anyway that'll do it for the
introduction to mad father hope you're
gonna like it so far it's seeming to be
an interesting adventure and expect a
lot of this while I am at Comic Con I'm
going to be playing this game and at
Comic Con there will be a lot of V logs
from me starring fans and whatever cool
stuff I find while I'm down there at
Comic Con so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always
see you in the next video
Oh God
Rivlin nothing her the movie
but here's a can I move through this
house normally